hi i'm maria bakalova i'm mahala i'm a
mandler my name is chase
hi i'm rachel and we are the cast of
bodies bodies buddies and we're here to
play a game of who's who with buzzfeed
i mean rachel
but not during this serious scene i
would yeah okay no no no no yes though
right
not like because you're out of character
because you're so you're [ __ ] dropped
into character and if you are bringing
the comedic relief necessary
i i feel like we were all kind of type
cast we definitely all connect to our
characters in a way hopefully no one's
too similar yeah
no it's like kind of an insult i know
like i'm sweating back here because i
just think it's me
yeah damn it but in a
thank you so much help in a panic
situation yes crisis you're the one to
call
maria yeah yeah yeah yeah i wish i was
more like
not introverted but more private now
with me it's like whatever goes to my
head goes straight out of my mouth
[Laughter]
[Music]
although i had to do maria the other day
for an interview yeah and she did it
pretty well yeah yeah that was good i
was gonna say maybe you i love you guys
so much
really really really you mean so much to
me
that was me
rachel's yes
whoa everyone takes them
you're taking zombies
i'm caught taking it
a little bit of a meme queen i'd say on
a meme page at once i do have a lesbian
lean page shut up are you serious it's
called highly dykely oh
must follow immediately
[Music]
it might be me not on purpose but
because i'm having usually two phones
one european one american and i don't
keep and truck very good so i miss
messages a lot
[Music]
honestly i steal underwear from zed wow
because
i don't want to
if i wear the set underwear i don't want
our customers to be like here you go
yeah like i would i will keep that yeah
as a favor to you i don't want them
that's rummaging all up in that yeah
also it's like no one it's not going to
be
you're not going to burn the underwear
you're not going to re-tag this and give
it to someone else
that's respectful stealing yeah that's
good yeah that's benevolent stealing
a party yeah i feel like that's all like
all that comes out of these interviews
is that like i'm korean crazy
rager i feel like we needed early on
like a hang i was so timid in the group
chat i'll never forget alina texted us
all i was like shopping with my friend
moss and i was literally like i typed
like 10 responses and literally all we
had to do was be like hey
yes
i actually remember that because i
didn't know that i didn't know that you
were cast yet it was like who this girl
was going off
to say her name yeah
and so anyways you made everyone feel
included in a in a hang yeah early on
first range or the first race first
range the first of many
[Music]
you can get good advice from everyone
like different type from a different
perspective yeah but you give great
advice thank you very much i feel like
i've had the deepest relationship talks
with you
same yeah i'm only sixty dollars an hour
don't worry well yeah
in the game that we did play maria won
for sure we might know maria's strategy
at this point yeah yeah we should play
we should play again
let's play tonight after the premiere
four in the morning oh my god let's do
it let's do it that's fun well you have
to play with me
and we have to see will you guess me or
no it's so scary
[Laughter]
i would say yeah on the first try to
learn the dance you knew the charlie xcx
one the other day that's true yeah you
were like oh i haven't learned it yet
but it's
yeah wait
i barely have any idea
i was like oh
oh god
[Music]
i will definitely be present there i
will be there as well we will be we've i
think we've always spent a lot of time
together
yeah
oh also you're like doing these like
weird overnights where you're like i
feel like you have strange cravings
we're all sending hits and you're like i
need a 3am pickle
people with a snickers bar we were
comfort eating a lot like we would be
like wet and cold and covered in mud and
blood and then be like i think i'm gonna
get an oreo
oh my god
that was good that was a beautiful prank
they told me i was doing a take and i
like wasn't in it and i was like what
are you talking i i they told me i'm on
break and i had like none of my props
and then i run downstairs like getting
into character like in a flurry and then
and then they all started turn to me and
smile in this like dark like death
chamber and started singing happy
birthday yeah yeah that was good it was
great those are perfect and we filmed
the whole thing terrified in 4k
for her birthday fully dropped into the
scene like
you guys
i think i actually felt and then helena
was like that was great do it every
single tape and there and there are
these giant wind turbines and like
hurricanes wind
yeah just
flying all over the place and i think i
just like slipped in the mud and fell
and then helena was like let's commit to
that and i was like um
[Music]
oh my god
really no because i drove to set
remember because i was going crazy
slowly
and that was the way i would i felt like
i've maintained my autonomy that does do
it i feel like there was not a lot to do
like there was no reason to be late
because we were like there's like a
motel in the middle of nowhere like you
want to get decent yeah yeah
you don't want to be the last person in
the motel it's a scary feeling yeah
thank you
go see buddy's buddies buddies
everywhere august 12th work period
[Music]
you